STEVE: I WAS DOWN IN FLORIDA
LAST WEEK, AND I SAW HELP WANTED
SIGNS EVERYWHERE.
DAN BONGINO IF FINALLY JOINING
US.
YOU WENT LIKE THIS --
BRIAN: YEAH.
REALLY HURT OUR FEELINGS.
FOR US --
>> YOU KNOW, THE FINGER I GAVE
YOU IS IMPORTANT THOUGH, YOU
HAVE --
STEVE: WE’RE NUMBER ONE!
>> RIGHT AS I WAS ABOUT TO GO ON
THE AIR, THE WHOLE WIRELESS
SYSTEM IN MY STUDIO CRAPPED OUT,
SO I HAD TO CALL YOU ON MY CELL
PHONE OLD SCHOOL.
STEVE: RIGHT AFTER WE DID THE
BIT ON RANSOMWARE AND RUSSIA.
AINSLEY: DAN, YOU’VE GOT TO
WATCH THAT BACK, IT WAS REALLY
FUNNY.
[INAUDIBLE CONVERSATIONS]
>> I JUST DIDN’T WANT YOU TO
START TALKING TO ME AND I DIDN’T
HEAR YOU.
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN EVEN WORSE.
SO I HAD TO GIVE YOU THE FINGER.
STEVE: SO, DAN, WHAT’D YOU THINK
OF BRATTON’S COMMENTS IN.
>> I WORKED UNDER CHIEF BRATTON,
AND HE WAS ONE OF THE GUYS WHO
STARTED THE WHOLE BROKEN WINDOW
STYLE OF POLICING.
AND I’M NOT BEING SARCASTIC,
BACK THEN IT WAS A BOLD IDEA
WHERE HE SAID, HEY, MAYBE WE
SHOULD START ENFORCING LOW-LEVEL
CRIMES.
YOU KNOW, USING THE GUYS WHO GO
ON TO COMMIT BIGGER CRIMES.
IN OTHER WORDS, TURNSTILE
JUMPERS WHO GO ON THE TRAINS AND
COMMIT MUGGINGS.
IF WE ARREST THEM FOR THAT, THAT
WILL PROBABLY LOWER THE CRIME
RATE.
AND HE’S RIGHT.
I’M GOING TO TALK ABOUT THIS
TODAY THE ON MY PODCAST AND
RADIO SHOW WHICH YOU CAN WATCH
ON FOX NATION.
GREAT PLUG THERE.
I HAD TO THROW THAT IN THERE.
THERE ARE THREE BIG, HUGE
THREATS TO AMERICA RIGHT NOW,
CRITICAL RACE THEORY, CHINA AND
THE WAR ON COPS.
ONCE YOU GET AMERICANS TO HATE
EACH OTHER FOR ALL KINDS OF
SUPERFICIAL CHARACTERISTICS, THE
BEST WAY THE ALLOW THE CHAOS TO
CONTINUE TO BREW IS TO ENGAGE IN
A WAR ON COPS AND STOP THEM FROM
ENFORCING THE LAW.
IT’S REALLY A DISGRACE.
LIBERALISM IS A FOREST FIRE
RIGHT NOW DESTROYING AMERICA
PIECE BY PIECE, AND WE CAN’T LET
IT CONTINUE.
BRIAN: RIGHT.
SO, DAN, BY THE WAY, I DID GIVE
YOU A BRILLIANT INTRODUCTION,
YOU JUST DIDN’T HEAR IT WHERE I
DID, IN FACT, PLUG YOUR SHOW.
LET’S LOOK BACK AT THE DAN BONN
GEE KNO SHOVER THE WEEKEND. --
DAN BONGINO SHOW OVER THE
WEEKEND.
YOU HAD A CHANCE TO TALK TO
JOCCO, AND THAT’S --
AINSLEY: WE WERE GOING TO PLAY A
SOUND BITE, BUT BECAUSE OF THE
MISHAP, WE’RE OUT OF TIME --
BRIAN: OH, WAIT A SECOND.
AINSLEY, CAN YOU PUT IT ON NOW?
AINSLEY: WE GOT IT.
HE’S SO WONDERFUL, FORMER NAVY
SEAL, HE IS SO STRONG AND HE
TALKS ABOUT WHAT MAKES AMERICA
GREAT.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> WE CAN CALL IT WHATEVER YOU
WANT TO CALL IT, YOU CAN PAINT
IT, PUT LIPSTICK ON IT, BUT THE
NATURE OF WAR IS DEATH.
THE NATURE OF WAR IS KILLING
PEOPLE.
IT ENDS UP IN CLOSE COMBAT.
IT’S HARD.
YOU CARRY A LOT OF WEIGHT.
YOU CARRY YOUR FRIENDS.
AND WE’RE TALKING ABOUT THIS
IDEA AROUND CRITICAL RACE
THEORY, TELL YOU WHAT I LEARNED
IN THE MILITARY THAT’S CRITICAL
ABOUT RACE, THAT IS WE DON’T
CARE.
WE WANT TO LOOK OUT FOR EACH
OTHER.
WE KNOW THAT WE FOCUS ON WHAT
OUR JOB IS.
THAT’S THE MOST IMPORTANT THING,
AND THAT’S WHAT YOU NEED TO STAY
FOCUSED ON IN THAT JOB.
AINSLEY: THAT’S WHAT’S CRITICAL
ABOUT RACE.
THAT’S INTERESTING.
DAN?
>> WELL, THANK YOU, EVERYONE WHO
WATCHED.
SATURDAY NIGHT, 10 P.M.
PLEASE WATCH IT AGAIN.
I DEEPLY APPRECIATE ALL YOUR
FEEDBACK.
JOCKO WAS AMAZING, I HAD ANOTHER
GUEST, ROGER FISK, AND I ASKED
HIM ABOUT CRITICAL RACE THEORY
WHICH INDICATES IF YOU’RE WHITE,
YOU SHOULD BE JUDGED AS BEING
WHITE AND SAYS YOU’RE AN
OPPRESSOR.
I WASN’T BEING A JERK, I ASKED
HIM ARE YOU AN OPPRESSOR?
AND HE SEEMED TAKEN ABACK BY THE
QUESTION.
IF YOU BELIEVE IN CRITICAL RACE
THEORY, YOU BELIEVE YOU’RE AN
OPPRESSOR.
I APPRECIATE EVERYONE TO WATCH.
AND RON DeSANTIS STRIKES
AGAIN.
HE JUST WENT AFTER IT AS WELL,
HE’S GOING TO BE TAKING ON
CRITICAL RACE THEORY IN FLORIDA
WHICH WE REALLY, REALLY LOVE.
STEVE: ALL RIGHT.
DAN, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.